- Welcome, everyone.
I'm delighted to introduce Duy Lap Nguyen
who is Associate Professor
in the Department of Modern
and Classical Languages
at the University of Houston.
His work, which is at the
intersection of history,
literature, critical
theory, and philosophy
breaks down conceptual and
disciplinary boundaries
that have long limited
the way we think about
important issues in Vietnamese studies.
He is equally at home
discussing the intricacies
of Marxist social theory
and historical materialism,
as well as at revisiting
the intellectual history
of 20th century Vietnam.
He's not only adept at
unraveling the mysteries
of Jacques Derrida or Walter Benjamin,
but at teasing out the
political, historical
and intellectual significance
of Vietnamese spy novels
from the late 1960s and early 1970s.
He writes regularly for
journals in critical Marxism,
and also forces us to rethink
the unsophisticated ways
most Vietnam studies
scholars have underestimated
and flattened the
intellectual complexities
of Vietnamese Marxist thought
and social theory within
Vietnam in general.
The results are provocative
and transformative
and show a path for engaging
with the history of ideas
and cultural productions
like literature, film,
and television, as a
serious intellectual project
that transforms the world
rather than just serves
as a derivative aspect
of political history.
Duy takes intellectual history seriously
as intellectual history.
It's not just a pathway into understanding
the stories we already
know about politics.
And this is what he is
done with this book,
"The Unimagined Community:
Imperialism and Culture
in South Vietnam",
which he'll be talking about today.
So please join me in
welcoming Duy Lap Nguyen
for today's talk.
Thank you.
- Thanks, Erik, for that
over-the-top generous introduction,
which I certainly don't deserve.
And thanks, Kristine, for
organizing all of this as well.
I've been a big fan of this series.
There's been a bunch of
wonderful talks in this series,
so it's a real pleasure
to be able to participate.
Okay, so I'm just gonna jump right into it
and share my screen with all of you.
Okay.
So on September 2nd, 1963,
Ngo Dinh Nhu, the brother
in chief political advisor
of the south Vietnamese
president Ngo Dinh Diem
spoke in secret with a Polish diplomat,
Mieczyslaw Maneli to
discuss the possibility
of peace talks with Hanoi.
In the context of the
deteriorating relationship
between the Americans
and the South Vietnamese
the meeting raised US
suspicions that Nhu was trying
to betray the Alliance
and forfeit the war.
The crisis was stirred by an incident
that occurred several months earlier.
In May, South Vietnamese
soldiers in the city of Hue
killed several unarmed civilians
opposing a government ban
on the public display of Buddhist flags.
The episode ignited a
wave of political protests
that would come to be symbolized
by the famous photograph
of Thich Quang Duc self-immolation,
shattering the image of
the South Vietnamese state
as a stable, viable and democratic
bastion of the free world.
The photograph would
become a universal symbol
of rebellion in the
fight against injustice.
Taken during the height of
the civil rights movement,
the picture appeared to
provide irrefutable evidence
that the Republic of Vietnam
was a repressive regime,
denying equality to its
own Buddhist majority.
The backlash in the international press
would prompt US officials to
threaten a withdraw of support
in a complete suspension
of aid at a moment
when the insurgency appeared
to be fulfilling its pledge
to quote, "destroy the
dictatorial government
of the American lackey", Ngo Dinh Diem.
In less than two months after
the meeting in September
Diem and Nhu were killed in a coup backed
by the American Embassy.
The assassination in
November marked the beginning
of a tragic comic cycle
of changing regimes
and incompetent leaders.
This ended in April, 1975
with the communist victory
and the humiliating
withdrawal of American forces
after two decades of war
that left millions of Vietnamese dead.
By that point, the Republic
was already widely regarded
as a political puppet,
manufactured by the world's
greatest capitalist power,
waging an imperialist war
against the poor peasant society.
So seen from this vantage point,
news response to Maneli during
their September meeting,
seems utterly strange and inexplicable.
After a lengthy. quote,
"exposition on the philosophy
of the cult of personality"
and its role in what he described
as the Republic's increasing
success in the war,
Nhu, unaware that the end had arrived,
announced the beginning of
a new phase of the conflict.
For the south Vietnamese,
the war had become a, quote,
"social revolution" against
the communist revolution
in the countryside.
As a total transformation
of society, this revolution,
moreover, was not simply
a nationalist struggle
to overcome communism.
On the contrary, nationalism,
according to Nhu,
was a, quote, alibi exploited
by third world leaders
who failed to recognize the
need for social revolution
in underdeveloped countries.
Casting the Buddhist affair
as an imperialist plot
to crush the social revolution,
in the name of a Western
ideal of democracy,
Nhu declared the quote,
"The war cannot be one with the Americans
because they are an obstacle
to the revolutionary
transformation of society
which is the prerequisite for victory."
This obstacle was identified in particular
with the mechanism of American aid,
which Nhu had condemned an unmistakably
Marxist terminology as an instrument
of underdevelopment, quote,
"Vietnam not a guinea pig
for capitalist imperialism
to experiment on."
The new phase of the conflict, therefore,
would call for resistance,
both against communism and
American neocolonialism.
The Republic as Nhu explained
to an astonished Maneli
is fighting against both the
guerillas and imperialism.
But even more puzzling than the idea
that the South Vietnamese were engaged
in an anti-Imperial struggle
with their American allies
was the fact that for Nhu the ultimate aim
of the social revolution in the South
was not to defeat communism.
Rather, the goal was the
abolition of capitalism
just as the Americans were now an obstacle
to the revolutionary
transformation of society.
So the quote, "capitalist
regime in the South
cannot effectively oppose communism."
In another display of this pension
for abstruse dialectical
statements, Nhu, therefore,
explained that the
anti-communist war was in fact,
an anti-capitalist strategy, quote,
"I am really combating
communism in order to put an end
to materialistic capitalism."
So this apparently implausible explanation
of the political aims of the
South Vietnamese government
has been taken as evidence
that Nhu was insane
as a symptom of his
opium induced paranoia,
or one of his Machiavellian schemes
to preserve his own power.
But it's just as implausible
that the leader of a
reactionary puppet regime
would try to avoid an eminent coup
supported by his neo-colonial patrons
by suddenly reinventing
himself as a Marxist opponent
of US imperialism.
And in fact,
Nhu had long expressed his
opposition to capitalism,
for example, in the manifesto
to his Can Lao Revolutionary Party,
where he writes, quote,
"The capitalists have
trampled on human dignity
to build a career of wealth
on the blood of laboring people."
Nhu's anti capitalist party, moreover,
would play an important role
in establishing Ngo Dinh
Diem's government in 1955,
a government which embraced
a version of socialism
that was different from
that of the communist party
with the Vietnamese Workers' Party.
As Nhu explained in an interview, quote,
"we are working towards
a socialistic state,
a non-Marxist state of free cooperatives
where labor shares control of industry."
Like the idea of an anti-capitalist war
against the Vietnamese Communist Party.
The notion of a non-Marxist socialism
may seem self-contradictory
given the capitalist/communist binary
that framed geopolitics
during the cold war.
And in fact, this led
one observer to argue
that the First Republic
was not a Catholic regime.
Rather, the Catholicism was merely a cover
for communism pure and simple, quote,
"Nhu fastened his grip on the
labor movement in Vietnam,"
and this is a fact that
sometimes forgotten
that he was a political organizer
before he became part
of the First Republic.
And Nhu "conducted the labor
movement under another name,
the Humanist Workers Revolutionary Party,"
which is the translation here for Can Lao.
"Stripped of its flowery rhetoric,
Mr. Nhu's non-Marxist personal Marxism
should never have been reassuring
the do-good Americans
claim that Ngo Dinh Diem
represented a third force,
hostile to communism.
The specious explanation
made him acceptable
to America's government and press.
In Nhu's case, the whole theory was rot.
Many Vietnamese were in
the third force category,
but Ngo Dinh Nhu was never one of them.
He was among the
intellectuals of the left.
In their game, the devout
Diem was never anything
but a front."
So this non-Marxist personal Marxism,
which was the official
doctrine of the First Republic,
is the same as what Maneli called
the philosophy of the cult to personality.
The theory informing the strategy
that the Republic was supposedly using
to fight the insurgency and
to resist the Americans,
the Strategic Hamlet Campaign.
So is there some validity
to Ngo Dinh Nhu's apparently
implausible account of the war?
Did the coup in 1963 marked the demise
of a corrupt puppet regime,
pretending to be a
parliamentary government,
or could it have been the
defeat of a social revolution
against the communist
insurgency in the south
and US imperialism?
So this is a question
that I explore in my book,
the "The Unimagined Community:
Imperialism and Culture
in South Vietnam".
And in my talk today,
which is taken from the
first part of my book,
I wanna reconstruct the lengthy exposition
on personalism and counterinsurgency,
which Nhu relayed?? to Maneli in 1963.
So what was this non-Marxist
personalist Marxism
that Nhu described as the philosophy
of the Strategic Hamlet Campaign?
And did the Nhu's actually
conceive of the program
as an anti-capitalist
war against communism?
And finally, what would
such a seemingly
contradictory project entail?
So to give you an outline
of my presentation today,
the first part will examine
the theory of personalism.
And I argue here that personalism
was not a reactionary religious ideology,
but a radical anti capitalist theory
that also included a critique
of bourgeois democracy.
This critique informed
the Nhu's understanding
of the impact of colonialism.
And the Nhu's perspective
is interesting here
because it departs
from the conventional postcolonial
account of colonialism
as being this hypocritical enterprise
that preached the rights of
man denying them in practice.
For the Nhu's, the
introduction of capitalism
and the liberalization
of law under the French,
acting in accordance
with the rights of man,
undermine the communal form of
democracy or village autonomy
that constituted the basis
of Vietnamese civilization.
And then in the last
part of the presentation,
I argue that it was this
communal form of democracy
that the Nhu's were trying to restore
in a modernized form through
the Strategic Hamlet Campaign.
The program was not simply
a counterinsurgency measure,
but rather, a full scale social revolution
aimed at democratizing rural
South Vietnamese society
while organizing the peasantry
into rural popular bases.
And these bases were supposed to serve
three real related purposes:
first, to contain the communist insurgency
using a version of the
communist people's war;
second, to isolate the
comprador capitalist class
in the cities; and three,
to limit the interference
of the American government
in Vietnamese affairs.
Okay.
So part one, Theory of Personalism:
Reactionary or Radical?
So when I began writing this book,
I kept coming across statements
by the early South Vietnamese leaders
that seemed to affirm Marxist ideas,
which seemed strange given
the conventional account
of the First Republic is
reactionary puppet regime.
So for example, Nhu, during
his meeting with Maneli
described the ultimate
aims of the Republic
in the following manner.
He said, "That is right.
I agree with Marx's final conclusion:
the state must wither away."
And then at a planning session
for the Strategic Hamlet Campaign,
Nhu emphasized what he called
"the first science of
organizing mass movements
based in the Soviet organization
of the communist in Russia."
(Duy Lap speaking in foreign language)
So what do the Russian Soviet councils
and Marxist ideas like the
withering away of the state
have to do with the reactionary
theory of personalism?
So to try to find some
answers to this question,
I went back to one of the primary sources
of Vietnamese personalism
which is the work
of the French Catholic
philosopher Emmanuel Mounier.
And Mounier actually was considered
one of the most important
philosophers in France
during the '40s and '50s.
In the literature on the Vietnam war,
this work is often characterized
as advocating a "third way"
between "Marxist collectivism
and Western individualistic capitalism."
So John Donnell describes the doctrine
as an "unsystematic melange
of 'third force' ideas,"
seeking a "middle-ground"
between communism and liberal democracy.
But as the French philosopher
Lucien Seve noted,
the third way that Mounier
proposed was in fact
much more directly aligned with Marxism
than liberal democracy.
Quote, "what characterizes
Mounier's third way
is not that it is situated
at an equal distance
between two polls.
On the contrary, it is
much closer her to Marxism.
The factor that unites currents
like the existentialism
of Sartre and his disciples
and the personalism of Mounier
and his followers is precisely
that they define themselves
with reference to Marxism."
So as Seve's description
suggests, Mounier's personalism
can be understood as a form
of Marxist humanist thought,
a category more often associated
with the work of thinkers
like Sartre and Lukacs and Henri Lefebvre.
Mounier's personalism, therefore,
as Nhu pointed out in an
interview with Le Monde
was not a conservative
ideology, but a radical one.
Quote, "We are a reactionary
regime you've been told?"
said Nhu sarcastically.
"Are you aware of the fact
that we take our inspiration
from the thinkers of the Western left?
But you must realize
that we based ourselves on personalism!"
Now, the concept of the person
in personalism is related
to both the humanist and Marxist
aspects of Mounier's work.
So in this work, the person
is defined as the foundation
for a philosophical anthropology.
The person is the ontological basis
of all knowledge and action
assuming the position of God
within Christian theology.
Quote "the person stands
at the summit of being,
and all being is subject to
a process of personalization.
Hence, the metaphysics of the person
will provide the ultimate
criteria for all praxis.
Mounier's philosophy then is a humanism
because it tries to explain
everything beginning
with the principle of the
human being or the person.
But Mounier also opposes
the concept of the person
to the egoistic individual
within bourgeois society.
In a capitalist economy,
according to Mounier,
an inversion occurs in which the freedom
of self-interested individuals gives rise
to what he called the tyranny
of production for profit.
As a result of the free
exchange of commodities
between individuals money,
which serves as a means at exchange,
becomes the aim of production itself,
subordinating persons to the
impersonal power of capital.
Quote, "under capitalism, it is not money
that is at the service of
the economy and people.
It is people who are at
the service of money.
For Mounier then the capitalist
economy is characterized
by a process of dehumanization
or depersonalization,
through which the people become dominated
by the impersonal power of
things, money and capital.
Subjected to what Mounier describes
with reference to the Marxist conception
of commodity fetishism, as the quote,
"mystifications into which
man has been inveigled
by social constructions
derived from his material conditions."
Humanity is ruled by a sovereign economy
that humanity itself has created, quote,
"it is not the economy that
is at the service of man,
but man who is at the
service of the economy."
So here, if you simply
replace depersonalization
with reification, then you get something
that looks pretty close to
Lukacs's criticism of capitalism.
And in the manifesto of the
Can Lao Revolutionary Party,
Nhu appears to incorporate this
concept of depersonalization
into the very platform of the party.
Affirming the principle
of personalist socialism,
Nhu declared the quote,
"production must serve the people
in contrast to the inhuman
condition in capitalism,
where it is man who is at
the service of the economy."
In Mounier's writings, moreover,
this depersonalized economy is described
as the infrastructure
of bourgeois democracy
or parliamentary government.
And Mounier rejected the latter
in unequivocal terms, quote,
"we hold all manner of
liberalism in horror,
for it is the greatest and
most evil fraud in history.
The most cunning and cruel hoax of all."
And this hoax was a legacy
of the revolution of 1789,
which according to Mounier
was not a popular revolution,
but a bourgeois revolution.
The function of this
bourgeois form of democracy
that was established by
the French revolution
was to ratify the despotic
rule of the capitalist economy.
In this political system,
the state does not represent
the people as such,
but rather, the universal
interest of atomized individuals
whose free interaction in the marketplace
creates the tyranny of
production for profit.
In Mounier's terms,
the role of the state
under capitalism is, quote,
"restricted to the
assurance that these egoisms
should not encroach upon one
another or on their betterment
as a purely profit making association."
Although Mounier, moreover,
was critical of the Soviet Union,
his critique of the latter
was not that it failed
to incorporate the positive elements
of capitalism and liberal democracy.
On the contrary,
the problem was that it was incapable
of completely abolishing capitalism
and the parliamentary form of democracy
that constituted its
political super-structure.
For Mounier, in fact, the Soviet system
was merely a collectivized
version of capitalism,
one in which the centralized apparatus
of what he called the massive Soviet state
organizes the exploitation
of proletarianized labor
in the place of the capitalist class.
So echoing Marx's famous
formula for social revolution
that quote, "changes in the
economic foundation lead
to the transformation
of the superstructure,"
Mounier argued, the quote,
"the liberal stage of
democracy will be superseded
only on the foundation of
a new social structure."
In contrast to the Soviet
Union, this new social structure
would not be a centralized government,
but rather what Mounier called
a communitarian organization
of decentralized communities.
Liberated from both the capitalist tyranny
of production for profit,
as well as from the
dictatorship of the proletariat,
which perpetuates the capitalist
institution of wage labor,
quote, "By socialism,
we mean the following:
the abolition of the proletarian condition
and the supersession of the
anarchic economy of profit."
Okay.
So part II: Colonialism and Liberalism.
This critique of capitalism
in Bourgeois Individualism
was adopted by the leaders
of the First Republic,
thus in a speech Tran
LE Xuan or Madame Nhu
declared the, quote,
"Our union will never be
a disordered collection
of individuals each following
the sole aim of personal interest.
Our union draws its strength
from unity and discipline."
So this personalist union
was opposed then to the market economy,
which according to Mounier
is based on an egoistic conception
of man as the, quote, "ideology
and prevailing structure
of Western bourgeois society
in the 18th and 19th centuries.
Man in the abstract, unattached
to any natural community,
the sovereign lord of a liberty
unlimited and undirected."
In the Vietnamese
personalism developed by Nhu,
Mounier's depiction of bourgeois
society is appropriated
as a critique of Western
civilization itself, quote,
"Occidental countries had for
their structure capitalism,
for their ideology liberalism."
For Nhu then, parliamentary government
is the political super structure
of a capitalist mode??/motor/ production,
which he associated
with Western societies.
In these societies, according to Mounier,
the principle of formal equality
and the abstract freedom
of egoistic individuals
conceal the concrete inequality
created by an economy based
on production for profit.
So this critique of capitalism
as a de-personalized society
of self-interested individuals
subordinated to the impersonal
rule of the economy,
informed the critique of colonialism,
that Nhu develop as part
of his Vietnamese personalism, quote,
"Under colonial domination,
man is subjected to money and power.
Such a regime favors the
egoistic type of man.
Against colonialism, the
Vietnamese Personalist
and communitarian revolution
conceives of human value
as independent of money and
residing in responsibility."
In the early colonial period,
the imposition of capitalism
was accompanied by an ambitious
French liberalization of indigenous law,
which introduced the individual
as a legal abstraction.
Instead of refusing to
recognize the humanity
of its Vietnamese subjects,
as the story usually goes,
the early colonial administration
attempted to grant them
their inalienable rights,
rights which had been
denied by the Imperial court
in its tyrannical regime.
Embracing what Alexander
Woodside referred to
as a social revolutionism,
the early colonialist conceived
to be Imperial project
as an extension of the French Revolution.
In the colony, therefore, the
rights of man were applied
in order to limit the political tyranny
of the Imperial state,
as well as the domestic tyranny
of the traditional family.
As the early colonialists
discovered, however,
the attempt to establish
these inalienable rights
would weaken the very foundation
of the non-Western society
they intend to liberate, quote,
"In traditional Vietnam, the individual"
as James Barnhart has argued
"was not really ontologically separate
from his or her family.
The notion of the
distinct civic individual,
the fundament of all
Western law was absent."
By applying what Marx
referred to as the, quote,
"so called rights of man"
separated from the community,
the French, therefore,
would unwitingly erode the
traditional bonds of community
that prevailed in the precolonial period.
During this period, the
country consisted of a myriad
of scattered semi-autonomous communes
governed by the Imperial court
whose seemingly absolute power
was in fact largely spectacular
limited to the ritual
exercises of sovereignty,
the coronation, the public
execution and so on,
as Ta Van Tai suggests.
The Imperial state was a sovereignty
that was almost completely
devoid of discipline
in the Foucauldian sense of the
latter as the daily exercise
of surveillance, operating
invisibly at the everyday level,
quote, "the Vietnamese diagnostic state
was a relatively weak
polity, without the ability
to reach deeply into all spheres of life,
because it did not have at its disposal
mass communications means
and a large police force
or prison system."
Owing to the weakness
of the Imperial court
and its tyrannical rule,
village notables, quote,
"manage local affairs,
and the family was the fundamental unit
of disciplinary jurisdiction.
Early French visitors were struck
by the remarkably decentralized nature
of social organization."
In the precolonial period,
the family in the semi-autonomous village
exercised a discipline
that preempted the role
of the centralized government,
lacking the disciplinary
apparatus of the modern state.
The despotism of this weak polity then
was never extended over
the entire territory,
nominally belonging to the emperor.
This weakness is expressed
in the traditional adage
(Duy Lap speaks in foreign language)
"the right of the emperor gives way
to the customs of the village."
In the precolonial period, therefore,
a despotic centralized state,
which lacked the power of discipline,
presided over a decentralized form
of directly associated
production based on the family.
As a Republic of Vietnam
government publication describes,
quote, "the social and political
organization of Vietnam
consisted of two opposing
and superimposed systems.
At the bottom there was
popular autonomous democracy,
at the top was the absolute monarchy,
which was highly centralized
thanks to its Mandarin system."
The Vietnamese nation, therefore,
was like a confederation
composed of numerous small
communal governments,
autonomous village communes,
which sprung up spontaneously
and adapted themselves to the
extremely centralized system
of the, quote, "Oriental
absolute monarchies."
Vietnamese society, as
Ellen hammer described,
was characterized by both a
highly developed autocracy
and a remarkable degree of democracy.
Now in terms of the
relationship between the base
and the super structure,
between the economic foundation
and the legal and political order,
the system was exactly the opposite
of the one imposed by the French.
In bourgeois democracy,
the formal equality
guaranteed by the state
conceals the existence
of concrete inequality
within civil society,
a contradiction that, according to Marx,
is characteristic of capitalism.
In contrast, the absolute sovereignty,
according to the Vietnamese emperor,
was merely a formalized tyranny,
in abstraction disguising
the concrete weakness
of Imperial power in the
democratic organization
of communal production.
In used terms, the official
autocracy of the Imperial state
was limited in reality by
the, quote, "democratic nature
of the autonomous organization
(speaks in foreign language),
of the village
and its independence in relation
to the central government.
Whereas the democratic rights
that the liberal state grants
to its citizens are
abrogated, as Mounier argued,
"by the facts of their
economic existence,"
the despotic authority of the
Vietnamese court was abrogated
by the economic autonomy
of its Imperial subjects.
The rights of the emperor
give way to the customs of the village.
If the emperor then exercise
in absolute sovereignty
over his subjects, this
formalized privilege
was subordinate
nevertheless to the village
and its extrajuridical customs.
In contrast, therefore, to
the legal right of the king,
the quote, "democracy and
autonomy in the village,"
as Diem pointed out,
"was not a written law,
(Duy Lap speaks in foreign language)
rather it was a "customary practice
passed down from one
generation to the next."
An extrajuridical form of autonomy
that preempted the people subjection
under the law of the emperor.
But as such the autonomy
of the emperor subjects
in relation to his
nominally absolute power
cannot be identified with the
inalienable right of freedom,
belonging to an abstract individual.
In Europe, as Diem pointed out,
the establishment of
this juridical freedom
had coincided historically
with a development of new forms
of coercion in techniques of control.
Quote, "in liberalism,
discipline is indispensable.
All economic activity is subject
to the exigencies of technique
which is imposed upon each
of us and prevents him
from acting independently."
During the era of industrial capitalism,
these disciplinary
techniques were deployed
in Foucault's terms for
the purpose of, quote,
"extracting time
and labor from bodies."
Adapted to the colonial context,
the new forms of discipline
provided the French with, quote,
"capacities to control and to coerce
never dreamed of by
previous Vietnamese rulers,"
which meant that traditional
village obligations
to the ruler, taxes, corvee
service, and military service,
could now be enforced with
unprecedented efficiency."
On the other hand, in
the precolonial period,
as Diem pointed out, quote,
"there was never an excessive
centralization of power
to enable conscription of labor-power"
on a continual basis.
Lacking the power to impose
a "daily exercise of surveillance,"
the "Annamite state," as one
French observer acknowledged,
"intervenes only on rare occasions.
It is indolent by nature."
And as Nhu pointed out, this
system of imperial tyranny
and peasant autonomy, underlying
Vietnamese civilization,
was undermined by the political
and economic liberalization
carried out by the colonial regime.
While the imposition of
capitalism and individual rights
liberated the people
from the personal rule
of a weak tyrannical sovereign,
it also subjected the peasantry
to the impersonal reign
of the market.
Quote, "The French," according to Nhu,
"have broken up the organization
of our social infrastructure",
(speaks in foreign language)
introducing capitalism
in order to "replace an economic system
based on the traditional village,"
and the "democratic nature of
this autonomous organization."
So this personalist Marxist
account of colonialism
underlies the Nhu's opposition
to liberal democracy,
which they viewed as a
legacy of the French.
For Nhu, the problem with
attempting to establish
a parliamentary state in Vietnam
was not that the Vietnamese
lacked the, quote,
"indigenous democratic tradition,"
having known only what General
Maxwell Taylor referred to
as the, quote, "oriental
despotic tradition."
Rather, the problem was
that this despotic tradition
was based on an entirely
different form of democracy,
one that was directly opposed
to that of a liberal democratic regime.
The Ngos, therefore, called
for the creation of a, quote,
"real democracy from the base
against formal and liberal democracy,"
a grassroots democracy created
through "communitarian labor
based on a social plan,
rather than submission
to the capitalist order."
This real democracy would restore
were the communal autonomy
of the Vietnamese village
in the modernized form
of a personalist system of
decentralized communities.
Now, insofar Diem regarded
this ancient tradition
as a sort of pre-modern equivalent
to the self-governing form
of the personalist commune,
his traditionalism paradoxically
may had put at him closer
ideologically to communism
than republicanism.
But if that is the case,
then the first Republic,
contrary to the conventional view,
was not an authoritarian government
pretending to be a bastion
of liberal democracy.
On the contrary, following
Mounier's Marxist prescription,
the leaders of the early
Republic sought to transform
the parliamentary state
in order to establish
a communitarian form of democracy,
quote, "the personalism that I advocate
is a militant democracy aimed at modifying
the super structure of
the present government."
Now out this personalist
communitarian revolution
was not simply an empty slogan or phrase,
rather the Ngos tried to
carry out the revolution
in a program called the
Strategic Hamlet Campaign,
which is usually characterized
as a counterinsurgency strategy.
For the Ngos, however,
the program was not a
tool of pacification,
rather the campaign,
which the Ngos defined
as the primary objective
of their government
was intended as a revolution
aimed at transforming
South Vietnamese society into a system
of semi-autonomous
self-governing communes.
Once established, these
decentralized communities
would produce what they called
a revision of the central
government agencies in Saigon
inherited from the French.
So this is Ngo Dinh Nhu
describing that process.
(man speaks in foreign language)
(Ngo Dinh speaks in foreign language)
So here Nhu is distinguishing
between his communitarian
brand of democracy
and electoral democracy.
And in the unimagined community,
I argue that this distinction
is vital to understanding
the first Republic as well as the reasons
for why it collapsed.
The difference between
these two kinds of democracy
is often elided.
And the elision underlies
opposing accounts of the conflict.
On the one hand...
I'm sorry, opposing accounts
of the queue in 1963.
On the one hand, this event
is portrayed as a consequence
of Diem's authoritarianism,
of his failure to unify
the Vietnamese people
by democratically broadening
his base of support.
Conversely, others have argued
that Diem's authoritarianism
was necessary in order to keep the country
from collapsing into rivaling factions
incapable of uniting the South.
In these opposing perspectives,
Diem's rejection of liberal democracy
is taken as a rejection
of democracy as such.
Historians differ, however,
on whether Diem's undemocratic
rule was necessary
for fighting the war, or whether
it undermined the Republic.
I argue that these opposite views
conceal a more complicated picture.
Diem was trying to
suppress liberal democracy,
while massively expanding
the communitarian form
of the latter espoused by his
personalist was government.
This was the aim after all of
the Strategic Hamlet Campaign,
quote, "Our Government aims
at one major objective:
the establishment of a truly
democratic infrastructure."
Although the Ngos then
were openly disdainful
of the electoral machinery
of the parliamentary state,
they were also committed the creation
of what they called a
democracy at the base.
Thus Nhu, who rejected
liberal democracy, quote,
reprimanded provincial and district chiefs
for not holding honest elections
for chiefs of strategic hamlets."
As Nhu explained, "Free, secret elections
of the hamlet chief and hamlet council
are the key to the success
of the strategic hamlets."
By providing the means
with which to institute
what he called "basic
democracy on a local scale
which the people can
understand," the Hamlet Campaign
would preempt the role of
the parliamentary state
and its centralized form
of electoral democracy,
quote, "Through the
Strategic Hamlet Program,
the Government intends to
give back to the hamlets
the right of self-government
with its own charter and
system of community law."
Because of the program,
hamlet leaders, quote,
for "the first time,"
as a senior US pacification
adviser observed,
"were selected by ballot
in most of South Vietnam."
For the Ngos, moreover, the
democratization of the villages
was as vital to the
security of the country
as their suppression of
their political opposition,
whom they viewed as members belonging
to an elite urban minority
that had little support
from the majority of the
Vietnamese in the countryside.
Thus, while Diem argued that
parliamentary government
must be suspended during
a state of emergency,
Nhu pointed out that the
war could only be won
by implementing in every
hamlet in south Vietnam.
Quote, "Your press" as Diem
explained in an interview,
"mocks the idea of respect for authority
and glorifies so-called civil liberties
and the need for political opposition.
But this country is in a
life and death struggle.
And even Western democracy
suspend civil liberties
during will war emergencies."
As Nhu explained, on
the other hand, quote,
"in time of war, people think
that you must suppress democracy to win.
To the contrary, we shall
use the war against communism
to introduce democracy,
and we shall use democracy to win the war.
This is the strategic concept.
Free elections of the hamlet
chief and hamlet council
by secret ballot are key."
So these two statements
are not contradictory.
The Republic was using
the state of emergency
in an authoritarian manner
to restrict an urban minority
from exercising democratic control
over this central government
agencies in Saigon.
At the same time, it was
implementing a program
of communal decentralization
throughout the rest of the country.
These two policies moreover
were directly related.
The Ngos conceived to the
program of rural democratization,
which they called the
Strategic Hamlet Campaign
as a kind of class struggle
against the French trained
elite in the cities.
In contrast to the rural population
who had supported the
anticolonial war, this minority,
according to the Tran Ngoc
Chau, consisted of, quote,
"bureaucrats, military
officers, and business people,
the majority of whom had
collaborated with the French.
When the French left Vietnam,
the French collaborators
became friends with the Americans.
What the Americans knew
about south Vietnam
they knew mainly from these Vietnamese.
It's not surprising, therefore,
that these Vietnamese
were also the ones to benefit
the most from American aid,
particularly the
multi-million dollar program
to build of South
Vietnamese military forces.
Meanwhile, in rural South
Vietnam, nothing much changed.
The peasants continued to be exploited
while the Americans were naively preparing
the South Vietnamese to
win a conventional war."
As Chau suggests then, many
among the elite in the city
subscribed to the formula
recommended by the Americans
for winning the war:
build up the national army to
fight a conventional conflict
while liberalizing the government
in order to unify the
south Vietnamese people.
As the Ngos recognized, however,
the aid program that benefited the elite
had created what Philip Catton described
as a kind of gilded underdevelopment,
one in which the abundance
of consumer commodities
concealed the destruction
of the country's
industrial infrastructure.
Quote, "the importation of consumer,
rather than capital,
goods created the illusion
of prosperity while
hampering the development
of local industry."
As sir, Robert Thompson noted, moreover,
the US commitment to maintaining
a costly conventional force
that was incapable of
fighting an irregular war
against the insurgency would
only increase the problems
produced by the commodity import program,
quote, "To pay the recurrent expenditure
on the armed forces, the
South Vietnamese government
was committed to accepting
indefinite American aid
on a large scale, including the import
of subsidized consumer
goods in order to generate
local piastre funds to
pay the army wage bill."
Insofar as the Republican
army was the main beneficiary
of the counterpart funds
created by the sale of
consumer commodities,
its existence was the main cause
of economic underdevelopment.
Against the urban elite and the Americans,
the Ngos conceived of the
Strategic Hamlet Program,
as a means of decentralizing the war
by building up local militia
while breaking the Republic's dependence
upon an economic assistance program
that was perpetuating
the underdevelopment.
As Nhu explained in an interview, quote,
"My ambition is that the fortified hamlets
may form a new approach better
than trying to get progress
as a gift of the capitalist societies."
It is "a solution to the central problem
of underdevelopment in the 20th century."
According to our report by a
Central Executive Committee
of the People's Revolutionary Party,
the solution would apply the same strategy
as the one used by the insurgency,
initiating a social revolution
to establish a decentralized system
of semi-autonomous rural
popular basis, quote,
"by establishing strategic hamlets,
the enemy would then have the conditions
for a mass manpower and material resources
to build additional forces,
increase military strength,
employ the civil guard and militia forces
to attack the revolution."
The solution to underdevelopment then
was to carry out a far reaching program
of social, political, and
military decentralization
in order to both win the
war against the insurgency,
as well as to limit American interference
using the leverage of economic aid.
The Republic, as Nhu
explained to Maneli, quote,
"is fighting against both the
guerrillas and imperialism.
And to end on a speculative note,
I'll suggest that it may have been
because of the increasing success
of the Strategic Hamlet Campaign,
that was behind the Ngos' adamant refusal
to liberalize their regime,
even in the face of a
complete suspension of aid
and a possible end to the US alliance.
So according to a US
state department report,
Nhu, quote, "will consider
present aid pressures
as a welcome excuse to bring about changes
in the rural scene and
perhaps in the whole economy."
these changes will be based on his desire
to get the Americans
out of the countryside,
in his belief that he has
a strong political base.
Now, the fact that these
changes were supposed to create
a decentralized form of
socialism in the South,
suggests that the war
during this early phase
was not a struggle between
communism and democracy
or nationalism and Marxism,
rather it could perhaps
be better described
as a struggle between two competing forms
of anticolonial communism.
Thanks.
- Thank you, Duy.
That was a fantastic talk,
a lot to discuss here.
So I'm going to open it up
to question and answer now.
If you can use the raise
hand function on Zoom,
please use that.
If you have trouble using
that, turn on your camera
and start waving your hand,
and I'll try to put you in a queue.
Well, people are thinking of questions.
I actually have a question.
I have several, but I'll start with one.
I'm curious, based on this talk,
where the Ngos' concept
of the village comes from?
You know, I'm an anthropologist,
and so I'm very interested
in social organization and
those kinds of things, right?
And it seems to me in many ways
that there's a kind of
imagined understanding
of what the village
social organization is.
And then when you showed that
image of the strategic hamlet,
it reminded me of things
I had noticed in the past,
the circular organization of
the strategic hamlet itself
is very similar to a kind
of red river village form,
going back in like careful studies
of Vietnamese village organization,
there's a wide proliferation
of village organization,
and Southern Vietnamese
villages tend to be linear,
whereas the ones in the North
tend to be these kind of circular
behind the bamboo hedge, so to speak.
And a lot of these ideas
about the emperor's law
seeds to village custom,
these are all like sort of folk sayings
that are quite popular,
but they become political theory in a way.
And so I'm just curious if you got a sense
of where their concept of
the village comes from.
And then a secondary question to that is,
they're working in Saigon,
developing these ideas at this time
about a kind of local level democracy,
which is very convincing the
way you put it in some sense,
but did they have a theory
of how that would play out in urban areas?
- So the first question,
I think the Ngos subscribed to parts
of this kind of nationalist mythology
about 2,000 year history
of the Vietnamese people
that was kind of invented
during the colonial period.
And so just as the communist in the North
were trying to cast their
struggle against the Americans
as the last kind of act
in this 2,000-year history
of resistance against
all foreign aggression,
the Ngos were trying to cast
the Strategic Hamlet Campaign
as the next stage in
this process of Nam Tien,
or the southward advance,
which was this important part
of the national mythology
that was created during
the colonial period.
And their idea was that
the strategic hamlets
would not only be kind of,
not just kind of a geographical expansion
of the form of the village as it was in...
But it would also be kind of this advance
into this non-Western
form of modernity, too.
So that's would be my answer
to the first question.
And then the second question.
Yeah, the geography, I
think, in south Vietnam
created a lot of problems for
the Strategic Hamlet Program,
and it was because a lot of these villages
were built along these canals
that the program ended up
needing to kind of forcefully
relocate peasants much more
than the Ngos had intended
the program to do.
Different from the Agroville Program,
because they wouldn't have to
move so many people around.
But I think because of the geography,
they ended up having to move
more than they anticipated.
And then the last question
you had was about...
Sorry, I'm.
- What I was asking was about the urban,
because this is kinda based on
a kinda an idealized version
of some kind of village
democracy or something like that.
How did they expect that might
play out in an urban setting?
Or maybe they hadn't thought it through?
- I'm not sure, but they imagined
that the social revolution
that they were initiating
in the countryside
would come back and somehow revise
the institutions in the cities.
But I don't have much more than that.
- We have a question from Charles
and then after that Christoph Giebel.
- Hi, Duy. Hi, everybody.
Duy, thanks for a terrific talk.
So I guess my question has
to do about the utility
of ideological interpretations
of the South Vietnamese state.
I'm asking the question because
the south Vietnamese state,
Goscha's used the term "archipelago state"
to describe the DRV state
in early parts of the war against France.
And I think the term is
useful in understanding
the South Vietnamese state as well.
I don't wanna call it weak,
but institutionally highly uneven.
And I think more importantly
characterized always by a range
of very diverse political
constituencies who
might not have been sitting
in the presidential palace,
but who exerted real political power.
So, you know, given that,
I mean, and, you know,
if you accept that characterization
of the south Vietnamese state
or of south Vietnamese politics,
I just wonder, again, what the utility is
of an ideological
interpretation of that regime.
I mean, I guess this stems
from me being a little bit uncomfortable
with characterizing South Vietnam,
as under the sort of umbrella
of the ideological vision
that you just described, right?
The fact that there were
constituencies in South Vietnam
that were advocates of liberal democracy
who didn't hold state power.
Does that mean that we
should not include them
in a definition of what south Vietnam was,
and therefore by extension a
description of what the war was
ideologically between,
as you described it,
two different competing
forms of communism, right?
And I guess my last point is that,
I ask this question because I fear
that ideological approaches
to understanding South Vietnam
have, at least historically,
inevitably been
kind of pulled seamlessly into
these kind of orthodox
revisionist debates,
and I think have kind of
precluded in some ways
deeper understanding of
South Vietnamese politics.
So anyway, I'll kind of stop
there and see what you think.
- Well, I think that
this ideological approach
at least kind of gets us around
this pervasive characterization
of the first Republic
as pretending to be something
that I don't think it
was pretending to be.
But like you were saying,
it did have to make so many compromises,
both with the Americans
and with all of these
other groups in the South
taking on the trappings
of democratic government,
in spite of the fact that
the Ngos were one group
that repudiated that form of government.
So, yeah.
So I suppose, insofar as the
ideological interpretation
kind of covers over the
fact that those compromises
had to be made with all
those groups though,
then it's not helpful.
I agree with that.
But yeah, at the same time,
and also I think it's a significant
reframing of the war because it's been
this consensus largely
that there are conservative government
on both the orthodox and
the revisionist side.
And, but yeah.
- Thanks.
- Sure.
- Christoph, go ahead.
- Hey, Duy.
I think your book is probably
one of the most exciting interventions
in modern Vietnamese historical
studies in a long time.
- Oh, thanks.
- So I'm very, very intrigued
by what you have produced
and the arguments that you're making.
And I'm speaking as somebody
who is not convinced
by the dichotomy of
orthodoxy and revisionism
when it comes to Vietnam studies.
I think it applies to some
degree in Vietnam war studies,
but I think it's misapplied
in Vietnam studies.
I think there are other
orthodoxies, but not those.
But in any case, kind of piggyback
a little bit on Charles's...
I think your argument is really
persuasive, it's intriguing
when it comes to the thinking of the Ngos,
but I'm wondering two things.
One is how much can we
talk about South Vietnam
as a unit, particularly after
the establishment of the NLF.
And the preceding suppression
of older Viet Minh networks
that must have riled up
a lot of the kind of longstanding networks
of revolutionary support
in the countryside.
During the time that the
strategic cabinets are built up,
but that is also the time
where the NLF is making
amazing inroads in the countryside.
By 1963, the NLF is projecting power
into probably something like a third
of the countryside south or the DMZ.
I see your argument at
that ideological level
and at the government level,
but what other consequences on this,
in the villages,
where does it go wrong, so to say?
I mean, I think this quote
from the central office
of Southern Vietnam, I
think it's very intriguing,
there there's clearly
nervousness about it,
but still there is an amazing amount
of territory that changes hands
until 1963 and thereafter.
And that would need to
be explained as well.
Thank you.
- Yeah. Thanks for that question.
Yeah, I think your point seems to be
a little bit like the point
that Charles Keith is making
about taking this ideological view
and how that covers over
a lot of important shifts.
So if you read through the Ngos account
and what's happening from
the beginning of the Republic
until the very end though,
is this sort of straight line story
where they declare the
foundation of the Republic,
it's a personalist democracy
embraces this personalist
concept of democracy.
And then they gradually sort
of realize their revolution
when they figure out how to organize
this Strategic Hamlet Campaign.
And so it's kind of the straight line,
but it sounds rather
that they're not really
sure at the beginning
how to carry out this
communitarian revolution
that they have in mind.
And they make a bunch of
compromises, like I was saying,
to sort of their political
opponents in Vietnam.
Sorry.
Where, for example, they
don't carry out as radical
the land reform as they
may have wanted though,
because they felt at that point
they needed sort of members
of this urban elite to
construct their government.
So that later on, by 1962,
they seem to kind of shift policies.
And so you hear the minister
of the interior (indistinct)
saying that we should have done
what they did in the North though,
and gotten rid of this class instead,
because now it's creating
all of these problems.
And so I agree that this
kind of ideological framing
of the story that was excluding
all those important moments.
But I do think that it's important to note
that, I think, against the consensus story
about why the Strategic
Hamlet Program fails.
The causality that's usually given is that
the program fails and that's
kind of the major catalyst
for the collapse of the First Republic.
But it seems from all
these different sources
that the program doesn't
really sort of begin
to completely stall until the coup occurs.
And so I think the causality
there is the opposite.
And it seems to me as if it
almost has to be this way,
because the generals
essentially get into power,
establish the revolutionary council,
and they can't decide on
anything except for one item,
and that is that they have to get rid
of the Strategic Hamlet Campaign.
So on November 2nd, they
go about dismantling
some 800 of these hamlets though.
And then the pace picks up after that.
I think that what they're actually doing
is essentially getting rid
of what is this kind of front
line in this political war,
that has no front lines, right?
So these are all the local militia,
the cadre at the village level
that are trying to keep communist
cadre from infiltrating.
And so yeah...
And so, I guess, that's what
I have to say about that.
- So can I follow up,
I mean, so why are they
so laser focused on dismantling
the strategic hamlets
November 2nd, 1963?
That's amazing.
I mean, is it that the school represents
the very kind of urban minority class
that the goals are railing against
are pushing themselves into power?
I mean, why are they so focused
on dismantling the strategic hamlets?
- I think the development of
the Strategic Hamlet Program
creates this sort of
antagonism between the Ngos
and the generals, because the
program is in part intended
to limit the role of the military.
And so...
Yeah, I mean...
And I think it partly has
to do too with the fact
that the generals were
largely sort of excluded
from much of this program as well.
But I guess, I think I'll
have to leave at that.
Sorry, this is sort of material
that's not fresh in my
mind right now, but...
Thanks.
Yeah, I'm sorry, like I'm in
the process of finishing a book
on a totally different topic though.
So part of this material sort
of not like in the forefront
of my mind, unfortunately, but.
- Duy, I wanted to ask another question
circling back to sort of the
philosophical side of things.
You had talked about Mounier's
philosophy of personalism
and in almost every statement
about Mounier's philosophy,
they always call him the Christian Marxist
or the Catholic Marxist.
And I wanted to take this
opportunity to learn from you
about what exactly, when they say that
on the book covers and those kind,
what precisely about
it is considered to be
the Catholic side of this
story, or the Christian Marxism,
as opposed to a kind of
Marxist humanism, per se?
- Right.
Well, Mounier, I think,
believed that capitalism
was this unchristian form of modernity,
that somehow God had been supplemented
by this kind of pagan
worship of these objects,
that now had power over persons.
But the funny thing about his personalism
is I feel that it
reconciles in a lot of ways
his Catholicism with his humanism.
So the concept of the person
occupies kind of the same
philosophical function as God.
And so the argument that he makes,
I think is something that like,
God intended to put sort of
humans at the center of things
because they're made in the image of God.
So he didn't think that his humanism
was in any way sort of in contradiction
with his Christianity.
The thing that I'm wondering about
is whether this was the
case with Ngo Dinh Nhu,
because in a lot of the
statements that he makes
he seems to be kind of rejecting
Mounier's Christianity,
while adopting this radical
part of his politics.
- Just building on that part,
you know, the standard refrain
in a lot of Vietnamese studies
is to talk about the importance for Ngos
of their Catholith or their Christianity.
Are you arguing in that sense
that that's the one thing
they're not interested in with Mounier?
I think a lot of people
would make the assumption
that it's because he's a
Catholic Christian philosopher
of Marxism that he's
actually somewhat acceptable,
but is that a totally wrongheaded reading
of their attraction to
Mounier's personalism?
- I think he was different
for each of the Ngos,
but for Nhu clearly the attraction
was less the Christian
side of it, I think though,
than the political side.
And so that's why he makes
these statements to the effect
that there's no relationship
between my personalism
and the personalism taught
by Catholic institutions
in France and in Vietnam.
But I'm not sure if it
was the same for Diem
and for the other brothers.
But I do think that the personalism
that they were trying to
put into practice was...
So one thing that I don't
focus very much in the book
is this whole kind of body of literature,
these pamphlets that were put out though
for the purpose of
popularizing personalism.
And I didn't like these very much,
because they kind of remind me of books
you can still find today
on Ho Chi Minh thought,
where they make these claims
that personalism combines
all of the best elements
of religions in Vietnam and in the West,
so the best of Christianity
and the best of Confucianism
and so forth,
and what they don't give you
is sort of this more rigorous
sort of philosophical arguments,
this political philosophy,
that I think the Ngos were
trying to put into practice.
But yeah, there is that whole
kind of religious dimension
that a lot of scholars
that work on personalism
have paid a lot more
attention than I have.
- We have a question from (indistinct).
- Thank you for this (indistinct).
I have questions: in some of your slide,
you talk about Ngo Dinh Nhu,
he said about the underdevelopment
of Vietnam at that time.
And to change it, they need
to change the structure
is very Marxist,
but during (indistinct),
I don't know if I miss it,
but he said about like
changing the superstructure
and underdevelopment
is related to a lot...
And they talk about capitalism.
And so, the changes that
they want to learn new
and the conflict in their political powers
is about communism and democracy.
And they didn't say anything
about economic strategy or something.
So maybe you didn't say
here, but in your research,
in your book, in another
part of your book,
did you mention anything
about the superstructure
like about economic
development at that time,
because they are under colony...
I'm not sure it's a colony.
They don't do anything for economic,
they live on the edge of the US.
So that's why they own about politics,
nothing about economics,
and the (indistinct) people,
because of that, they
just focus on politics
and the politics is
not just in the urbans,
in the center, in Saigon,
so that's why the rural was
match in the discussion,
political discussion about the strategy.
I'm going to learn from you. I don't know.
I'm not sure I missed it because
it's a lot of philosophies.
- Yeah.
See, well, the Strategic Hamlet Program
was really multifaceted program,
but a big, big part of that was
not political, but economic.
It was a rural economic
development program.
And I think actually the Ngos
actually thought a lot about economics.
And I deal with this in the book,
but there's also a lot of
recent research on the Ngos
and how they tried to
deal with the problems
of the commodity import program,
the American aid program.
And so I think for the
Ngos, they recognized,
maybe too late, right, That
the program was creating
this kind of (indistinct)
class in the South,
this oligarchy of wealthy
importers of US commodities,
and that these commodities
were coming into the country
and competing with local goods
and undermining industry.
And then those complained about this
to the Americans though.
So some of the Vietnamese research on this
is really interesting because they compare
the effect of the aid program in Vietnam
with a similar aid program in Korea.
And the Koreans were dealing
with the same problem as well,
though, where all of these
imported goods though
was making it difficult to industrialize.
And the way that the Koreans managed
to get out of this
situation was by offering
to sort of support the
US mission in Vietnam.
And that's when they got
to renegotiate the program,
so that more capital investment
was coming into the country.
And at that point, though,
as the war in Vietnam was beginning,
they began to more rapidly develop,
but they were having
similar problems in Vietnam.
And so I think that was part of the reason
why the threat of a
complete suspension of aid
didn't sort of influence the Ngos
in terms of liberalizing
their regime, though,
as much as the Americans thought it would.
But I think they thought a lot
about economic development.
I think they thought sort of
development was actually key
to winning the war.
And that sort of the American approach
of kind of like providing
all of these goods
to the cities that weren't
making it out to the countryside
and building up this huge army
and liberalizing the regime,
would simply continue to
lead to underdevelopment
in South Vietnam.
But yeah.
- Great.
We have a question from Jerry Silverman.
After that question, I'm gonna stop,
after you answer that question,
I'll stop the recording,
but I will keep the Zoom open
for a more informal chat.
So Christoph, if that's okay,
we'll have you ask your question
during the informal chat.
Go ahead, Jerry.
We'll flip that.
And Christoph, if you can
ask your question and then-
- [Jerry] Not mute.
- Go ahead, Jerry. We can hear you.
- [Jerry] Okay. I'm sorry.
- That's okay.
- [Jerry] I'm getting
used to the technology.
As a political scientist,
I'm also interested
in the nature of the
structure for governance
at the village level,
and whether or not you're talking about
closed villages in the North,
which I also agree is a
very different situation
than in the Southern Delta,
for example, on rivers.
At some level, you have a community,
even if it's in a linear sense,
it may instead of a village or a hamlet,
it might be a cluster of families,
but somewhere there's
an authority structure
that, quote, "governs" the entity.
And I've been playing with the notion
that the 1929 global depression
and an impact on that social structure
and that traditional elite
leadership at the village level
was alienated from the village,
prior to the revolution,
they were integrated into
the called capitalist system,
sending their children to
school in the district,
things like that.
And that as that happens,
non-formal leadership replaces that.
And that's a major social
revolution in and of itself.
And that accepting everything
that you're arguing
with respect to the Ngos
political philosophy and intent,
they were just way too late
because the situation
coming out of the '30s
had already created a, quote,
"modernized version" of life,
of political authority
structures at the village.
And therefore the war was
truly about governance
at the village level.
And that's where the competition was.
But that the NLF based
on the earlier Viet Mihn
had already started, you know,
they recognized that new
emerging village elite
as being the authority,
and the French and then the First Republic
did not recognize that authority.
Now that's speculative.
And you'll forgive me for
taking you back to the '30s,
but I wonder if you have
any reaction to that.
- Yeah, who's did backtrack?
Let me see that.
So I think the program of democratization,
the way it was supposed to work
is that instead of giving the population
the ability to vote
for powerful interest in people in Saigon
once every few years,
the idea was basically
if you can give people
some measure of democratic
control over things
that mattered immediately to
them, including their security
and which development project
they wanted to engage in,
that you can motivate
them politically much more
than if you simply extended
electoral democracy.
And this is partly why the Ngos
were describing this program
as a social revolution as well,
because they wanted to get rid of,
they thought that by implementing
these democratic elections
and allowing the population to get rid of
kind of existing groups with privileges,
that they can motivate the
population to organize itself.
I'm sorry, I don't know
enough about this moment
in the '30s that you're
talking about, when sort of...
Are you saying then that sort
of the colonial structures
of administration had
broken down at that point
and you already have kind of a
modernized village structures
at that stage?
- Well, if I could
respond just very quickly,
no, I'm really talking about,
well, what I call parallel governance,
that I accept the notion that
the traditional Vietnamese
was that villages, hamlets,
I would go so far as families
could govern themselves,
but that the structure of authority
within that context had shifted.
- Right.
- [Jerry] From the traditional elite
to the people who emerged to the degree
that the traditional elite had
to some degree abandoned them
because of the depression,
they had a choice.
They could either choose
living in the district
or they could choose continuing
their role in the village.
And many of them chose the district
because they had already bought
into the French colonial economic system.
The elites in the village.
And without those elites,
new leadership had to emerge.
And my speculation is that it
emerged within that village
from among people who were still there
and that the communists recognized that
and co-opted that new
leadership and recognized it,
and the French colonial
system then, the Diem,
did not recognize it.
So that even though there may
have been parallel attempts
to democratize the system
down to the village level,
at least in rhetoric,
that the Ngos were just
20 years or so too late.
- So it may well be
that they were too late
in beginning of this program,
but I think they did recognize
the problem because one
of the explicit aims
of the Strategic Hamlet
Program was to kind of build up
this local elite as a
kind of counterbalance
to what the Ngos perceived this
sort of French trained elite
in the cities that had
kind of been trained
in this like centralized
form of government
and weren't capable of acting politically
and autonomously and so forth, though.
So they were trying to sort of recreate
what the communist were doing
in terms of building up
this local elite as well,
but it may have been the fact...
But they were starting very late with it.
And I'm sure that was a
difficult problem to overcome.
- [Jerry] Thank you very much.
- So that's the last question
of our formal discussion.
So before we switch to the
informal session, everyone,
please join me in thanking
Duy for a fantastic talk.
- Yeah. Thanks for showing up, everybody.
- (applauding) Q&A.
I will stop the recording.